From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
Docent: Welcome to the
Library of Congress.
Dr. Hayden: We are opening
up the Library of Congress,
our treasure chest, to everyone.
Opening up means we are
making it accessible.
Travis Painter: At the
Library, we offer tactile tours
and visually-described tours.
So walking over where we see Thomas
Jefferson's bust standing three feet
high, we're able to describe
that-watching people put their hands
on the bust and connect
with a piece that otherwise
that they would not
have the opportunity to.
Vicki Radcliffe: When you are blind,
being able to touch some
things makes a real difference
in how you are able to perceive it.
And the descriptions are very
good that the docents are giving.
Docent: This is the pedestal.
Dr. Hayden: The Library of Congress
is the world's largest library,
and as a result, should be a
leader and a model for everyone.
Access to the Library's collections
is one of our primary goals.
And access means accessibility.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov